we've talked about colonization so I
think this is worth mentioning um kind
of puts a cap on that conversation this
is a report from CNN a profile really
about a musical artist a a
decolonization rapper and you already
know this is right up my alley because
it brings all the things I love together
decolonization rapping Etc brings it all
together so this is what it says CNN uh
reports when Frank Wallen wraps on stage
he's dripping head to toe in his culture
his long braided hair frames his face
and Lota jewelry gifted by relatives and
fans hangs from his ears usually
porcupine quills or buffalo bones as
handwoven bracelets wrap around both
wrists a beaded Medallion beats against
his chest as he sings his voice
reverberating with pain and anger every
lyrics sizzling with the fury of
unavenged
Injustice um the Lakota rapper Born and
Raised on the rose bud reservation in
South Dakota tours the world merging
hip-hop and Indigenous music into
distinctive Soul stirring songs WM said
quote I grew up in a place that used to
be a literal death camp where they
marched My Tribe to die I was raised by
survivors who could never talk about
their trauma because they're still in
survival mode surrounded by survivors of
the atrocities of colonial violence the
award wi winning rapper says he has
always carried with him centuries of
their heartache through music he says he
found healing and the opportunity to
take back the freedom American
colonizers had stolen from his people
and it goes on me this is a long this is
a CNN okay and this is a long profile on
this guy claiming that he's a
award-winning is touring the
world brilliant poetic artist speaking
out against Colonial Injustice bravely
speaking out against alleged injustices
that happened 200 years ago and uh but
let's let's listen to a little bit from
uh this guy of course this is what
that's this is all leading to and this
is what you all want to hear so here is
I believe this song is called
concentration camp
blues and let's listen to a little bit
of
[Music]
it
check
1212 concentration
bles never makes the
newsers r the game when they made the
rules let me try to paint a scene of
chasing lonely red Kit dreams with
nights banging out beats on that top
screen with but
youring uh by the way that song has
12,000 views on YouTube in two years and
so this is the the guy that CNN gave a
whole lengthy uh profile to allegedly a
a world
touring revered awardwinning
artist um and uh I I well I like the
song Because for one reason only which
which is that you you don't often hear a
recorder in a rap song and I don't think
I've ever heard one in a rap song before
and after hearing it in the song I guess
I realize why you don't usually hear
them in songs uh but it does give me
hope because the thing is that the
recorder is the only instrument that
I've ever somewhat successfully managed
to play it's the only one and uh I mean
I can at least play Hot Cross Buns I can
play Twinkle Twinkle Little Star on the
recorder so it gives my musical dreams
my musical dreams are reinvigorated
everyone knows I love my Helix mattress
but did you know that they just launched
their newest most high-end collection
Helix Elite Helix has harnessed years of
extensive mattress expertise to bring
their customers a truly elevated sleep
experience the Helix Elite collection
includes six different mattress models
each tailored for specific sleep
positions and also firmness preferences
I've had my Helix for years and I love
it it's the best mattress I've ever had
if you're nervous about buying a
mattress online you don't have to be
Helix has a sleep quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else go
to helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body type and
sleep type your mattress will come right
to your door for free plus Helix has a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will their financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night sleep is never
far away Helix is offering 20% off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
my listeners go to helixsleep.com Walsh
this is their best offer yet and won't
last long with Helix better sleep starts
now this is who CNN gives a whole
profile to on their on their site even
though the music is I mean obviously
objectively uh terrible but this is part
of this process that we that I talk
about where um the on the
left you know they have they used to
dominate culture they used to dominate
music films art in general and they
still do but I think think that that um
domination is going to start to
wne because whereas they used to put the
art the quality of the art above the
message now they've completely flipped
it you know and they're doing what the
Christian uh music industry and film
industry for so long had done on the
other side of
it putting stuff out it's like you like
the
message and so you pretend that the
quality of the it's high quality art
when it when actually everyone realizes
that it
isn't and now the left is making the
same mistake which I think ultimately is
probably a good thing for the culture
thanks for checking out this video if
you'd like to listen to my full podcast
on the go you can check out the Matt
wall show on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you get your podcast